and John for you obviously lovely that
Emily wants to be in the fur but as a
director is it then weird giving your
life-partner notes it was weird because
I was very nervous about to be honest I
think we both were before we started
shooting she said are you nervous and I
said I'm terrified and she said oh good
me too I think it's one of those things
where people think because we're both in
the same business we have the same
experiences but I've actually never been
on set with her seen how she worked I'd
heard she was a diva and I just can't
get Emily out of her trailer stuff I had
and nobody I think what it was is and it
sounds really sappy but it's true I
think it's the greatest collaboration
I've ever had in my career I I've never
seen her work and when you are actually
in the room and she does what she does
it honestly it changes the air in the
room everyone is just completely and
totally stunned by what she does
I have to learn early on in our oh
that's relationship was that British
people are notoriously terrible at
taking compliments would you agree just
like
actually what she did I just want to get
out of the way I'm a huge fan here's
we're cool at all there was none of that
actually I don't know your work you are
a proper fan oh I was full stalker
status yeah I was just like hey how many
times have you seen Devil Wears Prada I
mean not 75 give or take 72 it's one of
those things that back in the day us
elderly people used to chant and no one
does that
[Laughter]
it's just one of those movies that
whatever whenever you're going through
the channels you just stop and you mean
look
has anyone seen the film here there's a
sort of montage sequence where Annie
Hathaways got numerous fabulous outfits
that they go through and John one day I
came home and he was watching it and and
he was watching the montage but he goes
that's my favorite outfit
beany I couldn't get an e and so
[Applause]
[Music]
you